okay you might not be positive you might
not be negative
what else could you be if you were
neither you could be zero okay so if
your second derivative is zero I have
some bad news for you which is you don't
actually know yet right because you're
like ah it's not concave up it's not
concave down okay if this is the case
you need to go a bit further and you
need to say sorry we were trying to
avoid this but you're gonna have to go
with that second derivative and get a
table of values okay you're like hmm
it's a bit weird why is that well I'll
show you in a second but first I want to
illustrate based on what you already
know okay how could it be that you end
up with a horizontal point of inflection
we'll have a look at your arm have a
look at your piece of paper okay on that
my completed one is up here we're in the
middle row right we're in the middle row
because we've already found that there's
a stationary point somewhere and we're
just trying to work out what kind of
stationary point it is okay so if you
find out your second derivative is zero
as well as your first you've being zero
it could look like this do you agree so
it's not a maximum it's not a minimum
it's a horizontal point of inflection
question I don't know why this means
random but that's fine that's okay okay
good questions so the cubic function is
the easiest example of a horizontal
point inflection that you guys know
about there are others but but these are
the easiest ones and that's why when you
look at it I hope if you look at this
graph you like that looks like a cubic
to me right other functions can look
like that too but that's the easiest
most accessible example in your brain
okay okay good now a horizontal point
inflection you can see it's in the
middle of my table so it this first
derivative is zero here it is the
secondary is also zero so there's no
concavity so you might have a horizontal
point inflection like that okay you
no because you can look at the concave e
on both sides okay can you see concave
up and then concave down the change
means that there's a point of inflection
or here we go if you're concave down and
then concave up that change means
there's a point of inflection okay so
coming back to your flowchart now we
here it is am I going to see if I hear
this okay how do you know you have a
horizontal point inflection and the
answer is if you have a change in
concavity if you have a change in
concavity you already know it's a
stationary point it goes from concave up
to concave down or vice versa that's
going to be a horizontal point
inflection okay but then you're like
wait a second what's all there's only
other lines like there's more lines
going other places okay I'm gonna give
you example I think all right at this
point I'd love you to go to your book
now can you go to your book I need a new
page here because I've run myself out of
space and in your book I want you to
write a little subheading for me and
that is the special case not special k
the special case of y equals x to the
four okay so this is what we're gonna do
and it's gonna feed into this flow chart
we're having a look at okay but I've
been saving this one up now let's think
about this guy in terms of what we've
been working on like find stationary
points find out what kind of stationary
points you've got okay so you've got
your flow chart right in front of you
how do I find stationary points when the
first derivative equals zero fantastic
so what I want to do is find out that
first derivative and then I'm gonna
solve for when it's equal to zero so
help me out differentiate what's the
review this is an example for X to the
power of three
okay so hold on don't get hey yourself
I've got my first derivative right
stationary points exist when when that
guy is zero right so I'm gonna write
when dy on DX equals zero okay I know
what dy/dx is it's 4x cubed because you
told me so that's equal to zero and
hopefully because I've given you a
simple enough example you can tell me
what x value makes that zero it's helped
me out guys it's zero if I put X equal
zero into there you get the first day of
being zero so x equals zero there's a
stationary point there okay now normally
I would follow my um flow chart I'd find
out what the y-coordinate is but I'm
actually wanting to go to the next step
a little more quickly so I want to find
out what kind of stationary point this
is okay we can do this by using our
table values with the first year in the
secondary but I'm like hey man I've got
this fancy second derivative can I use
this right so I'm going to find to
determine nature I'm going to find the
second derivative so I'm going to use d
squared Y on DX squared now I don't even
know what the second derivative is we
haven't worked it out yet so can you
help me work out what the second
derivative gives that was a rhetorical
question please help me work out what
the second area is you tell me 12x
squared fantastic so here's my second
derivative and the whole point of using
the second area is I don't have to do a
table values cuz I'm like I can just
find out what the concavity is right
there okay so I'm gonna say oh when x
equals zero what is this second
derivative
well it's twelve times zero squared and
that's still zero see like oh it's a
stationary point there's no concavity so
what kind of a stationary point is I
still don't know is it a horizontal
appointment inflection now this is
important right points of inflection if
you come back to UM your table right you
either go from concave up to concave
down or you go from concave down
concave up it there has to be a change
right it's like that situation with the
pandemic over I'm looking for a change
in concavity so how do I know whether
it's changed I've got to look to the
left and I've got a look to the right
does this seem does this sound familiar
again right so I have to draw a table
values okay so I'm gonna do an X value
okay so I need to pick some values just
on the left hand just on the right so
negative whoopsie-daisy
laser pointer negative one and one sound
pretty good just be on the left on the
right okay let me draw an actual table
around here that might actually help
okay let's start the easy bit I already
know what happens at x equals 0 the
second derivative will be 0 right I
already found that out okay when I put
in x equals negative 1 you get 12 times
negative 1 squared 12 times negative 1
squared which is 12 because the negative
gets squared okay trap for young players
all right what happened-- sequels 1 it's
12 times 1 squared which is also 12 wait
a second
everyone put your pens down because this
is a critical moment hmm pens down pens
down and look up please we need to think
about this carefully pens down
I'm still waiting for all pens down
because I need 100% of your
concentration what do we know so far
there's a stationary point here yeah I
know there's a stationary point I went
and found concavity and I'm like oh
there are there is no concavity it's
concave not concave up concave down so I
went to look for whether it changed from
concave up to concave down or vice versa
does it change in concavity it does not
it's concave up before and then it's
concave up afterwards so it doesn't
change from up to down it doesn't change
from down to up and they're changing a
cavity so what does this thing actually
look like
and the answer is it looks like this
what is this thing now you wouldn't be I
wouldn't be surprised if some of you
said that looks like a parabola right it
looks like Rob Lowe it looks like a
parabola that's gained a bit of weight
right you see that look at the bottom do
you see how it's very flattened down
okay now it looks very much like a
parabola but it's not because right at
the bottom there as we have just
determined without you know a second
derivative there's no concavity a
parabola is always concave up or it's
always concave down this guy right at
the bottom there whoopsie-daisy right at
the bottom there doesn't have any
concavity like it's a stationary point
and it has no concavity right bit sad
right so so what is this guy what is
this guy now you can come back to your
um your big enormous flow chart
whoopsie-daisy
sorry is this a horizontal point of
inflection answer no because there's no
change in concavity right this guy
happens to be this particular is a
minimum right it's at the bottom right
so it'll be a minimum if you are let me
write it for you concave up and then
you're after your stationary point you
might still be concave up I know that's
a bit weird but that's what we got and
it's a minimum because you're like oh
it's always concave up that's going to
be a minimum how do you get a maximum
what do you expect the second derivative
to be on either side it'll be concave
down and then it'll be still concave
down it'll be this one we just had a
look at but upside down right so I'm
just gonna write that in let's do it in
pink concave down to concave down
now it's worth pointing out that what we
have down here at the bottom of the
flowchart
it's pretty uncommon it's so uncommon I
had to come up with a very special
example case to show you that it's
sometimes a bit weird okay but it does
sometimes happen okay so are you getting
is it possible that you get given that
in the exam maybe you can see if I gave
you y equals x to the for it's not that
complicated looking like it's not weird
crazy algebra or trigonometry all that
kind of thing you can differentiate it
you can differentiate again you can find
out all the things you need to know you
just have to be careful okay but it is a
special case it doesn't happen
frequently which is why you can't see
I've kind of shoved it at the bottom of
flow chart because I'm like guys this
doesn't happen often but it can happen
okay does that make sense it's a little
bit like honestly it's like the hazard
lights on your car you don't use them
often you don't want to use them often
but you need to know it's there for when
you need it make sense